now first thing i'll do is ask the
committee to introduce themselves
and i'll start with myself i'm
councillor chris lever
representing northern ward
can i start with peter
good morning my name is peter christie i
represent biddeford north
good morning my name is pete watson i
represent broad east good morning my
name is rosie lot i represent two rivers
and three wars
good morning i'm margaret brown and i
represent great charmington
hi i'm ruth craigie and i represent the
east
good morning i'm richard and i represent
heartland ward
hello i'm richard wiseman i represent
the shelby and langtry ward
good morning my name is devin goff and i
represented
and now i'll start with the uh officers
on my left with our planning manager uh
good morning members good morning
members of public my name's sean
harrington and i'm the planning manager
at our district council
good morning my name is stacy doran i'm
the head of legal governance of the
tourist street council
good morning i'm laura davis my
principal plan monster
my name is sandra the committee clerk
good morning i'm kirsty and i work in
demo services as well but i'm operating
youtube
and we've got matt collins from denver
county highways
and if you'd like to introduce yourself
yeah i'm mike from the dcc ecologist
hello
[Music]
[Music]
all right okay thank you
right okay
well we're not expecting any fire drills
so
if the alarm does go off and we didn't
happen a few weeks in the back
the way out is the way you came in
please don't use the left
if that's the case
[Music]
[Music]
item two on the minutes
of our previous meeting on pages
five to twelve
we'll move on from the chair or second
or two
can cancel watson and second with those
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
item 3 on the agenda is declarations of
interest
and members with interest to declare
should refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interests when the item has been
considered
elected members of denver county council
and town and parish councils
who have considered the planning
application by virtue of their
membership of that council hold a
personal interest and are deemed to have
considered the application separately
and the expressed views of that council
do not bind the members concerned who
consider the application afresh
and
item four on the agenda is to agree
between parts one and two there is no
part two
five is urgent matters five on the
gender urgent classes i have nothing to
bring up and that much about the chair
sean hasn't thank you
six is public participation
um this is where i've got to let the
committee know that there are speakers
requests to speak
and what we've got for the first
application which is the landmark monks
farm in trilogy
there's a statement from the parish
council
which uh sean our planning manager will
read out
and then speaking against the
application we have steve crowder
speaking as a member of the public but
representing cpre as well
mark marion speaking against the member
of the public
we have
sarah rocks
in support who is the applicant
and mark bernard in support and over the
public
and that's for the first one for the
second one which we are considering this
morning brunswick harris
torito laura
laura lee davis speaking in support for
that one and councillor bus bushby
will speak as well
[Music]
this afternoon
well i'll read those out when they start
again after lunch for the benefit of
people who might come to them
okay
i do
when we met in the town hall and i
always read out that
because we've got quite a few members
not quite a few members of the public
here
it is expected that all who attend the
plans committee that they will give a
fair and uninterrupted hearing to the
planning officer giving their report
to all those listed to speak and to the
planning committee members when they
begin their consideration
and after all i always had its only
common courtesy thank you
so we move on then to planning
applications
uh item seven on the agenda
the information recommendations and
advice contained in the reports are
correct
at the date of preparation which is more
than 10 days in advance of the committee
meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes or necessary updates
to the reports will be provided in
writing or orally at the committee
meeting
so we move on then to our first
application
which is on page 13 of your agenda
and
this is the application
um
for the months farm called trigonometry
and i'll introduce laura davis who's
going to take this and present the
report thanks laura thank you chair can
everybody hear me
so the application is for the
installation of a 42 megawatt
photovoltaic
with the associated grid infrastructure
and associated works now i've got quite
a number of updates um and i've gone
into quite a lot of detail about these
i've put these in the next these slides
and i apologize i'm going to take a few
minutes just to run through but given
the nature of the application
[Music]
so in terms of representations we've
received a further seven letters of
objection following the publication of
the officer's report
these raise many of the same concerns as
those already set out in the officer's
report including the citing and
landscaping impacts
and noting the number of objections that
have been submitted to the application
in addition concerns related to the
likely impact on local tourism economy
and a lack of sustainable development
and potential in pollution from
construction works have also been raised
from us
i've also got two letters of support
we received one note in the legal
renewable energy
and emphasizing that point in the second
indicates the potential employment in
relation to ecology surveys for the site
and in relation to the plan numbers
there are a couple of just typographical
areas um
in those relates to the first four set
out on the slide there there's just a
zero that's being missed out on each of
those plan numbers and the final plan
number one which is on the list in the
process report should be removed because
that's been superseded the amended
version is already on our plans list
[Music]
and we've also got some amendments to
the conditions
and condition three is only a
typographical error so it should read
when the land ceases
to be used as a photovoltaic park and
condition eight which is in relation to
highways should refer to condition four
and not condition three
um
condition 10
uh makes reference to the outline
construction environmental management
plan
that isn't it's correct it's just the
date that was incorrect it should be the
first of march 2021 and not 2020.
um
i would recommend that we amend or add
into condition 14
and the details of the other or cultural
assessments so we make clear which our
cultural assessment is so we add in the
bit which says prepared by
neo-environmental date of the 1st of
march 2021 just to be clear and make
sure the enforcement point of view
the future and condition 15 um that we
received an updated ecological impact
assessment so the dates should be
altered um and that refers to the
biodiversity management plan and the net
gain assessment as well the dates
are all set out there on the screen they
should prepare to the may date not the
march
um condition 17
there's just a typographical error with
the word or
the nature of e added
and at the request of the highway
officer i'm going to add an extra
condition which is the next slide
which
become condition 19 of the
recommendation which is prior to the
commencement of any other part of the
development here i agree
the passing places shown on those
drawing numbers shall be constructed on
site in their entirety um so that's to
ensure that we've got the passing places
on the surrounding roads in advance of
any compelling construction starting and
so we put that board as a
pre-commencement condition
and
opposed to ensure that planning
authorities satisfied with the impact of
construction traffic generated by the
development on the local road network
and to ensure that there was no adverse
impact on highway safety
so we'll move on to the presentation
itself
um site location plan and the
application site's outlined in red there
with the little outline
of the
remaining land in the atkins ownership
public highway that extends through the
site from east to west are showing the
yellow there along the other public
highways and strengthen the area
monk's farm is shown as the orange
collection of buildings to the to the
north of the public highway and jelana
farm to the south
and you can see derral water is noted on
the right hand side there
the gray lines indicating the existing
power lines that run through the sites
and the existing substation is located
on the right hand side there is again a
little orange box
[Music]
and
indicating the application sites and so
you can see monk's farm to the north of
the
public highway sheliana farm the
buildings associated with that to the
south and you can also see the existing
so far the credit card farm
which is just on the right hand side of
the photograph there
i'm just taking an extract here as i did
in the site visit the members just from
the applicant's landscape and visual
appraisal just for the purposes of
identifying where some of the following
photographs are taken from um so we've
got photographs were taken from within
along the main highway going through the
sites and then the surrounding public
footpaths as well as some from the south
west to south east
so i will run back through the same
photographs that we looked at visit
so the first viewpoint which is taken
from the western side of the site
from the public highway from a field
gate and he's looking north
from nearby's farm
[Music]
from the same point
okay and then viewpoint two is from a
similar location on the west of the site
uh through a field entrance nearby's
farm but it's looking south into the
application site now
and so the applications don't start the
underlying trees that's
shown
there
and again i've taken photographs
from the same point
these are taking a little year so
slightly different vegetation
my viewpoint three is to be looking
south across the site from sort of the
central point of the site
um from a field gate entrance opposite
new park and monk's farm
and we see the existing pylons
and then again i take the photograph
from a similar point
and then the app is submitted some photo
montages as well
from this point which this is included
in the landscape visual appraisal and
this shows the proposed development at
year zero um so without any landscape
mitigation in place
[Music]
existing substation foreground
and this is on the eastern side of the
site
a partial view into
the eastern part of the proposed
development and in the distance there
and again i've taken some photographs
around this area so this is the existing
substation
[Music]
and then these through to the
application side beyond
and view along the eastern boundary of
the site from
so just just a refreshment as to where
we're at with the viewpoints um we'll go
to 3.5 now which is down to the south
east
of the site so you get more of a
distance view
and this is
wouldn't be visible from this point due
to the intervening trees but it would be
the distance there and i think we
identified on the site is it that it's a
pirate church that you can see just on
the horizon there
so again i've taken both photographs
from the same location
viewpoint six and it's to the north of
the site and they're hot worthy farm
so from the product highway further
north of the site again it's a distant
view
beyond the planted field that you see in
the foreground there and again i've
taken some photographs
[Music]
so just for um
some members orientation we'll go to 3.7
now which is on the public footpath that
leads down to critical farm
so we're on the eastern side of the
right hand side of the plan now
obviously path number three
so we'll be looking west towards the
site
so this is from the uh division
appraisal we have a view beyond the
immediately
adjacent field
[Music]
this one again is more distant views and
power lines give us an indication of
roughly where the application site is in
the eastern boundary of it
and then i've taken some photographs
from the same point
i'm also showing the relationship
between chronograph farm and their
existing selling farm
back towards towards prince
the applicant has submitted again um a
photo montage from this angle and it's
showing the
proposed development in relation to
critical fantasy council see it's there
it's adding the gray
left hand side of the photograph
and then that's
zero so no landscaping integration
and then
the subsequent picture
the photograph shows you with some
landscape mitigation that's as good as
it would be at year five
and
[Music]
[Music]
the application site just outside just
south east of
southwestern looking down towards the
site and
again you can see the pile on things
with the marker of the eastern bathroom
again photographs are taken from the
same
position uh the outfit has again put in
a photo montage from this point so this
is showing the proposed development as
viewed from that point at year zero so
there's no landscape litigation
and then
year five
with
[Music]
around the area of the previous
viewpoint showing high edges to either
side and sort of the glimpse easier to
get a bit towards the application side
uh i've been including some pictures
here for um
to for members understanding of the
surrounding area this is the sort of the
eastern boundary of the site so this is
the main road you can see there running
through the site and the bridge over
down the water and then he's looking
north along the eastern boundary of the
site
and then some views looking
[Music]
and
just for general information for members
this is queen of fox and so i'm as it
appears today and just showing members
um how the hedges uh have been retained
on this one
and how it appears
as i say it's a completely separate site
about how it deals with the associated
infrastructure and the psychopaths
just for information
this shows the other questions in the
context of other solar farms and wind
turbines in the surrounding area and so
so far we've kind of got being the
closest one to the application sites
we've got purple shaded area showing me
the certain farms
[Music]
and proposed solar panel arrangements
and so they will be 2.8 meters in
heights
which will be their maximum height
mounted on an a-frame
and put in a distance of 2.6 meters
between each row of panels
next slide please
basically cctv cameras to be located
around the perimeter of the site which
will extend to a height of 3.5 meters
proposed acoustic fencing is to be added
around three of the um inverted
substations located closest to balanced
farm to litigate any noise disturbance
that's recommended in the acoustic
assessment
proposed security fencing which would
extend to a height of two meters
and posterior fencing which will extend
around the entire site to a height of
2.4 meters with mesh fencing in the
posts
and then showing and the elevations and
plans of the inverted substations 14 of
these in total positioned around the
site
each including the transformer cabinet
and the substation container
and the proposed grid substation one of
those on sites to the southeast of the
site
and a larger compound
a proposed construction compound these
would be temporary with two of them in
total one located in the northern part
of the site and one to the south
this shows
[Music]
[Music]
west lake cottage which is set to the
south
west and north more
nearest neighbours to the south
hot weather farm where one of the
equators taken is located to the north
and bounds farm is located to the west
of the application site so the blue
shaded areas show the location of the
solar panels
and the pink lines around those areas
show the fencing around
it's proposed to retain the majority of
the hedges
and two access tracks will be formed
into the site to the southern section
and two into the northern parts and
there's noticeable black lines
for access for construction
and they like the one large grid
substation shown there in pink
dark pink
lower part of the eastern side of the
boundary and then you can see the
inverted substations they're indicated
in red
dots across the side
this is the proposed hall route for
construction traffic which is amended
within the application
timeframe
it now directs traffic through
holdsworthy via underlying run and
viable industry is initially proposed
that's the proposed landscape and
environmental management plan uh i
apologize it doesn't go out any clearer
than that
but it shows the proposed areas of
planting additional habitat creation
with
smaller areas of pedro removal proposed
to allow fence lines to be installed
that includes
with green lines
the darker brighter green lines i guess
and for the new hedgerows and it also
indicates intrigue lighting as well
uh i've included a slide just to show
the relationship of the application site
to the non-statutory
uh environmental designations so just
these were highlighted within the
environmental impact assessment and just
to note the proximity and development
which is to the southeast of the site
and the annotation block's just going
off the bottom of the photograph there
which extends back into across the red
line there
um amendments were made within the
application process to ensure that no
development is undertaking including
events in within that area
and then the applicant has submitted
individual sheets showing
plans showing different parts of the
application site and so this is just
showing the site overall but it i'll do
as i did for the site visit just to run
through them
the members understand
i've been zoomed in viewing each part of
the site
[Music]
[Music]
yellow
[Music]
station
it's july's on which will be changed
let's see relationship cottage
[Music]
[Music]
but just to highlight the key points
um
the principle of renewable energy
development is supported both in
national and local policies subject to
the consideration of landscape impacts
local amenities and ecology
and in addition cumulative impacts and
development should be considered in
relation to other renewable energy
installations in the surrounding area
in terms of agricultural land
classification
the agricultural land in the application
sites associated with the existing
agricultural enterprise of montevallo
and trilana
as existing trelana farm is used for
beef cattle and dairy whilst monk's farm
includes some holiday properties some
areas left re-wilding and grass growing
to the silage cuttings being sold onto
the dairy farms
and i believe members have some
questions about the
nature of
the area of the
agricultural holidays that will be used
for this so just to
provide some further clarification the
application site covers 66 hectares so
by my calculations that's 163
approximately acres
and so the soda farm would use 30 acres
for a month's farm and there's a total
of 180 acres there
at
farm the application site which results
in use for 135 acres
from a total of 400.
okay
so the application site includes
39.8
of land in grade three a
backwards landing quality
land
forty two point seven percent in grade b
moderate
i've got landed twelve point four
percent being great for poor quality
as noted in nasa's reports and natural
england's response has noted that the
existing farmland would only be lost on
a 10-40-year basis
and the nature of the installation is
not likely to result in a high level of
soil disturbance
natural england have however noted that
considerations should be given to
whether the development is an effective
use of agricultural land in accordance
with the npdg and queries of
consideration alternative sites
and this is addressed in the officers
reports noting that the district does
not have large areas of brownfield land
by its very nature
and which will build a similar scale to
the concise proposed development
and issues with soil types and drainage
on the site are noted with poor drainage
and lack of access into some fields the
machinery during the winter months
further constraining
the potential agricultural use around
in terms of landscape character
and from the photos and photo montages
showing much of the site will be
limited in terms of public views due to
the existing high hedges and also
footpaths and public highways
and views of the application site would
be able to be gained from existing field
entrance gates as existing
a full assessment of the landscape
impacts is discussed in the artists
report but just to draw the attention of
the members to the conclusions of
the applicant's landscape and visual
assessment and then also those of the
council's own independent review of this
which was undertaken by
the lever and steve was here to answer
any questions that you have today
specifically in relation to this element
um consideration should also be given to
the proposed landscape mitigation
measures and they're set out on the
landscape environmental management plan
including planting new hedge banks
which would assist in assimilating the
development within the surrounding
landscape
as particularly relevant in relation to
consideration 3.3 as we've seen
attention members is also drawn to
condition 16 within the recommendation
which seeks to secure these landscape
measures
along with condition 15 in relation to
mythology and condition 14 in relation
to tree protection
in terms of the impact on historic
character the closest list of buildings
are noted within the offices report has
been at a distance of over 800 meters
from the site and there are no relevant
conservation areas which would have
with the development of not having that
impact on any of their settlements
um the council's conservation officers
rating objections
the county council's archaeologist has
commented on the development
noting that the application site is in
an area of archaeological potential
further trial clenching has been
undertaken by the applicant
and the county council's archaeologist
has now recommended a condition included
to
ensure a written s investigation will be
um submitted and approved in advance of
the placement of any works on site in
conjunction with the county council's
ecologist
in terms of residential amenities
the relationship with the nearest
neighboring properties
is identified on the plans and
the officers report sets out the
distances to the nearest neighboring
properties at bounds farm
criminal crop farm north moore and west
lake cottages
um
the members reference the existing
properties at monksvine trilana and that
at new park which is just at the
entrance to mike's farm
are within the landowner
its ownership the atlanta being involved
in this development
and the applicants also confirmed that
this is the case for westlake after
general educators
consideration is given within the report
to the likely impacts of the various
elements of development on each of these
properties
we've received comments from the
council's environmental protection
officer in relation to the acoustic
assessment submitted
and this is recommended that acoustic
fencing means added
around the three inverters that are
closest to bounce farm
where the likelihood of noise
disturbance from the development would
be greatest
and in addition the environmental
protection officer's recommended
condition
to include
be included in the recommendation to
ensure that the noise levels resulting
from the development do not exceed a
certain threshold at the boundaries of
neighboring properties and that's
condition 12
in terms of security
as you saw the development will include
positioning of cctv cameras adjacent to
the fence and around site
uh deer fencing is proposed around the
entire site which will include mammal
gates to allow some smaller wildlife
training
security fences were placed around the
inverted substations
uh no specific objections have been
raised by the police as designing
outbreak uh officer in relation to
proposed developments
it is noted that concern's been raised
in relation to the potential angling of
cctv cameras in some representations
we've received
and noted the potential for overlooking
and it's proposed that these are angled
into the site condition 17 seeks to
secure this
in terms of highways access
the proposed development will include
the widening of four access points into
the site construction phase two to the
north and due to the south
details of these works together with the
resulting visibility displays the access
track construction and proposed passing
places
along
the adjacent public hierarchy and
specific consideration
the county council's high resource
officer has raised no objection to
proposed development subject to a number
of conditions which has set out nearest
report and the additional condition 19
outright at the beginning
so these seek to ensure the provision of
passing places in advance of development
a survey of the surrounding road
network to ensure any damage is
rectified
and and provision of hard surfacing
for the first sections of the access
track to ensure that the delivery
doesn't come up on the public highway
there are also conditions in relation to
the outline construction environmental
management plan
and the construction traffic management
plan uh matthew collins the high risk
officer from the county council is also
here to answer any queries you may have
in relation to
aspects of development
um the police department would not
directly affect any existing public
rights way although members will note
the comments of the rights away officer
in relation to potential views from
those rights away and particularly
viewpoint number nine
and the construction phase
as indicated in the plans we have two
temporary construction compounds
and with the construction method
statement outline construction
environmental management plan
setting out how the development would be
undertaken
we've included a condition within the
officers report um in relating to
construction working hours since
condition 11
and consideration has also been given to
the decommissioning phase
um an appropriate condition
included and that's condition three
in terms of drainage and blood risk
majority of the site is within flood
zone one we've got some small areas
around air and water which are located
in flood zones two and three all the
proposed uh solar panels will be located
in flood zone one
and we have a buffer retained between
existing water courses and field drains
and proposed development
in terms of surface water drainage the
county council's flood risk engineers
have reviewed
the submitted details and they've
recommended amendments throughout the
process
and we've now got proposals submitted
which relates
to the circle to run off
in part during the construction process
but mainly during the operational phase
to include swales and infiltration
trenches across the sites to accommodate
any additional surface water runoff and
condition five has been recommended by
the county council
and seeking to secure further details of
exactly how the surface water will be
managed in the construction phase
in terms of ecology and biodiversity
we've got an ecology impact assessment
being submitted in support and that's
been independently reviewed by the
county council's archaeologist mike
waller again who is here today to answer
any specific questions you may have
and the ecological impact assessment was
amended in response to comments from
natural england
and along with the biodiversity
measurement plan
and this relates in parts of the
relationship development to the derral
water unconfirmed wildlife site to the
south and east from the site
and plans have been amended so that no
development would have been undertaken
in in that area and we've had a
subsequent response from natural
language saying that they have no
objection in that
respect
and condition 15 of the recommendation
seeks to secure the development
to be undertaken in accordance with the
submitted ecology report and the
documents
submitted along with the landscape
environmental management plan which was
in presentation
in conclusion the
report considers that the development
would result in an acceptable landscape
impact when taking account of the
proposed mitigation measures
and the nature and sighting of the
development of the surrounding
undulating landscape
with the recommendation recommended
conditions set out in the office report
and as i've earlier this morning the
recommendation is for approval
right okay thank you
the first
public participation the plus
contribution is
as i announced at the start from byron
the
parish council
and then shortly as a statement from
them to be ready so
thank you chair
[Music]
uh can members hear me clearly
so it's a statement from highway parish
council
members of highway patch council are
unable to attend the plans committee
meeting on 4th of november relating to
the work planning application
however they request that the following
point to be read out prior to the
decision being made
this has been a very controversial
planning application a size of which is
vast in relation to the overall
footprint of high wiring and combined
with existing solar developments within
the parish it accumulates to over 400
acres which equates to 5000 tennis
courts or 50 wembley stadiums
as a parish council we are mindful of
the wishes of the parishioners
the overwhelming objections from the
local community are proof that this post
solar park is not wanted in this rural
location
this is evidence from the numerous
letters to gtdc opposing this planning
together with all the ejection signs
erected in and around the village of
highway
whilst there are undoubted benefits of
solar panels as an alternative energy
source protecting the world we live in
especially with continued climate change
and evidence of global warming
but these benefits are negated if it is
to be built on farmers
we must protect the countryside around
us and secure this for future
generations
do we really know that the true benefits
of solar are worth sacrificing acres of
good agricultural land
whilst the proposed solar development is
for 40 years at which point it will
invert back to land not agricultural
lands will it then not be a brownfield
site
for many of us we will not be here to
find out but our children and
grandchildren will
do we want to be the generations to
change the face of highways become a
solar village rather than a rural
village it is it should be
we feel there is we feel there is an
increased realization that covering
farmland with solar panels is not the
most effective option
devon as you know has the best grass for
raising cattle and sheep because of its
climate and this proposed new solar farm
will use 66 hectares
losing fast farmland to solar also
increases our reliance on imported
produce
which is not the best practice
especially as we risk public but also
being encouraged by british
official climate also has many cloud
dates which means that solar panels good
on farms are not as effective and
potentially less reliable
farms at sea and nuclear power are much
more productive and will probably be the
way forward
we are especially concerned that a
displaying patient goes ahead then it
will only be a matter of time before we
are faced with further solar
applications in our village
thus covering even more of these will
definitely side with industrial solar
panels
we urge you the councillors to follow
the lead made recently by councillors at
mid devon and refuse this application
for reasons of its adverse cumulative
effect
and the loss of good quality format
thank you sean
right when our first
public speaker speaking against the
application is
steven crowe
if you'd like to come up to the
microphone at the table thank you
and once you've settled you've got three
minutes to present your case thank you
ladies and gentlemen good morning
uh you're already aware of the multiple
objections to this proposal raised by
local residents local councils
consultants and environmental bodies
like devon cpre
you will know about its 10 to 12
operating efficiency the famous duck
curve that shows solar farms produce all
their energy when it's least needed
grid stability issues harm to landscape
and heritage assets
toxic contamination of land and the
effects on local wildlife
but as cock26 is sitting
the climate emergency is uppermost in
our minds
you may be inclined to say yes
but we must we must take what action we
can to save the planet we must be seen
to be doing our bed whatever the cost
this is laudable
but i would like to add to your
consciences two important factors which
you may not be so aware of
the first is slavery
i don't know where the solar panels will
be coming from for this array but it's
more it's most likely they will be from
china because that's across the reasons
where most of them come from
and if that's the case then there's a
high probability that they will have
been mined in manufacturing manufactured
using some of the 2.6 million forced
labourers from the wiga community
if you've not read the report in broad
daylight by sheffield hallam university
i strongly recommend you to do so
the second is that in trying your best
to combat climate change you may
actually be destroying one of the best
tools you have to do just that
cop 26 has declared that our clear focus
must be on deindustrialization
reforestation and land regeneration
devon has the best quality land for
rearing she for the rearing of sheep and
cattle in the world by none
it is purpose-built to increase our food
security and self-sufficiency and thus
reduce the carbon costs of food in
particular importation which are huge
but it is even more than that
it is now increasingly recognized and
this has been the subject of growing
coverage in recent months that
regenerative agriculture involving a
mixed and rotational agrarian economy in
which animals fertilize land for crop
growing land is mulched rather than
plowed and allowed to recover rather
than degraded by intensive farming in
chemicals could be the most effective
way of capturing carbon
carbon catcher is much talked about but
it is still an elusive theory that the
leading world authority on regenerative
farming the rhodale institute has
calculated that regenerative farming
could sequester more than 100 of our
carbon emissions in 15 years
that's why major corporates like nestle
and unilever and others are investing
billions in the idea amazon just this
week pledged a further billion dollars
to land regeneration
each time you approve a 168 solar array
on denver's agricultural gold plan you
take an average you take an area the
size of the average devon farm out of
the solution
each one represents another whole farm
gone
a farm which using the gold standard
agricultural asset that is under your
studentship
could be providing a natural and
restorative solution to net zero
the precise solution cop26 is calling
for and one which doesn't involve any
slaves
please reject this application on the
basis of policies sg07 sg14 and st 16
and the national planning policy
guidance on cumulative impact
thank you very much
thank you mr crowder i'll just get the
table wiped off again before
marion is a speaker
when you settle you've got three minutes
also
to present
thank you i'd like to thank the
committee for allowing me to speak
against his proposal i'm uh mark
marietta and i've been invited to speak
on behalf of over 200 community members
who oppose the plan
without doubt we're in support of
renewable technology in the right place
but we have to be innovative and not
just roll over to big industry who want
to make money
as we've heard cop26 has highlighted the
need to de-industrialize and regenerate
green spaces
this proposal does exactly the opposite
the planning officer's recommendations
missed but we feel largely overlooked
the concerns of the community which were
called out by our ward councillor on our
behalf but he's been denied the
opportunity of representing us here
today parishioners are most concerned
that the impact the application will
have on the character of the countryside
if this is permitted this small rural
community will have handed over more
than 400 acres of once-productive
farmland to industrial use
and since the committee is to take a
view on the cumulative effect of the
proposal on the planning policy sc-16
and the mppg
we would ask you to consider how big is
too big
if 400 acres isn't industrial then how
much is 500 acres 600
nearly 40 percent of the land of the
proposal is grade 3a classes best and
most versatile agricultural land which
under planning policy st 14 and the mppf
should not be released from food
security and i quote without the most
compelling reasons
further to this the impact on the
agriculture in the area is yet to be
understood the proposed land is enough
to provide 1.5 million liters of milk
enough for one third of the population
of torridge
which will now have to be imported
significantly increasing the carbon
footprint of food
the response from the community has been
overwhelming and people who have lived
here for many years have remarked on how
we've never been so united around the
common cause
they're also concerned about the lack of
engagement and the power of apathy res
has shown us
neighbors have still to be properly
consulted res have steadfastly refused
to visit the area or take part in events
and regen a member of the national solar
commission have publicly stated that res
should be closely engaged to resolve the
parishioners issues
this simply hasn't happened despite what
they say on the bbc
for tourists to permit such a disengaged
business partner to destroy local
communities farmland jobs and libyans by
turning our parish into the industrial
sense of the profit is an insult to the
community
and the worst kind of green washing
possible destroying land in the name of
the climate crisis
you have sound and valid planning policy
reasons to justify refusing this
application
and now is the time to make a stance and
reject it as your fellow district
councillors in mid-devon cornwall and
shropshire have recently done in similar
situations
we should also take the opportunity to
invite future applicants to think how we
can respond to the climate crisis
together without damaging the fabric of
our society and to leave a joint legacy
for future generations
thank you
thank you mr marriott for your
presentation
the next speaker in support of the
application is the applicant
for sarah roberts thank you
way more settled
i've got three minutes as well okay
thank you
good morning and thank you for allowing
me to address the department committee
my name is sarah rox and i'm the project
manager for the applicant res
last month the government published its
net zero strategy which sets out the
policies and proposals needed to make
the ambitious target with net zero by
2050.
it confirmed that solar and wind will be
the backbone to achieving a secure
affordable and low-carbon energy supply
which means that as part of the energy
mix large-scale solar projects such as
the proposed sterile water application
have an important role to play
the darryl water solar farm is a
carefully sided and designed solar
project the site was chosen as it has
good irradiance is close to a viable
grid connection
can be easily accessed and lies outside
any statutory environmental
archaeological and landscape
designations
the fields where the proposal is located
are in most parts well screened by
existing vegetation helping minimize
visibility
a substantial landscaping plan is
proposed which as well as further
reducing any potential visibility of the
solar farm will provide a plentiful
source of food and shelter for a range
of wildlife
the site has been designed to include
significant biodiversity enhancement
measures such as the installation of
bird and black boxes which will provide
an overall net gain in biodiversity
units of over 90
as welcomed by natural england in their
consultation response
we've listened to feedback from the
local community and statutory consultees
and made a number of changes to the
design and response in order to minimize
impacts even further
these changes include removable variants
to reduce the visual and cumulative
impact and to avoid a priority habitat
and have half the site area from 123
hectares at pre-application stage to 66
hectares in the planning submission
although we understand the arguments for
use in brownfield land over agricultural
land for solar development a look at the
council's brownfield land register
indicates that there is only 20 hectares
of brownfield land spread across 17
sites
this is not sufficient to achieve the
net zero targets
the project would produce over 40
gigawatt hours of low carbon low cost
electricity every year equivalent to the
energy needs of approximately 12
thousand tons
as well as offsetting significant co2
emissions over its lifetime compared to
equivalent generation from fossil fuels
the project would provide around 162 000
in business rates each year
helping to support vital local services
as well as delivering inward investment
to the area and jobs during the
construction and decommissioning phases
in summary this project has been subject
to comprehensive environmental and
technical studies and has received only
one objection from statutory council
days
in conclusion the planning balance is
strongly in favor of this application
therefore we respectfully ask the
planning committee to support this
application in line with the officer's
recommendation thank you
thank you for your presentation thanks
and
[Music]
our next speaker is mark mark bernard in
support of the application
thank you
once you're settled you've three minutes
awesome to present you
thank you so much
can you hear me if i stand uh
[Music]
mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to speak
here this morning in favor of this
application
my name is mark bernard and i found the
terrain farm in partnership with my wife
sarah
as such we are the majority landowner
involved in this application along with
my neighbor tonight for months farm
my family has farmed to chelana since
1962
i am the fifth generation of my family
to the farm within partly parish
consequently we are totally embedded
within primary village
dairy farming at montevallo sees in 2003
and three of the barns have been
converted into holiday acts and this
business will continue as the solar farm
goes ahead
no livestock are kept at monk's farm
we are on the dairy speculator and we
farm in the region 400 acres
with no succession in place and the
infrastructure needing substantial
investment to continue to continue to
continue
as a dairy farm the decision has been
made to see sterifying within the next
two years
irrespective of any making today
if this application is improved we will
still have over 250 acres of open
grassland terrain
and we will continue farming beef cattle
and provide employment to our younger
team members
already at chilena
two of our members of the existing team
are looking to retire once the dairy
herd has disbanded
over 60 of the land of chilean months
remaining 40 percent being mostly 3a
historically all of this land has been
defined by debra as a less favored area
we have shallow topsails and a heavy
yellow clay subsoil
leading to frequent water logging
our current intensive methods of
management of the ground leaves very
little room for our native wildlife
the establishment of a solar bomb will
dramatically reduce the intensity of
this management and lead to ecological
benefits
this is confirmed by an independent
ecology consultant commissioned by
tyra's district council who concludes
there will be a 90
habitat gain with this project
most of you all would like to see our
countryside remain in this green fields
we do have to remember this agricultural
landscape is man-made
climate change is real
and we have the responsibility to take
action for the safety of the future
generations
cop 26 is taking place in glasgow as we
meet
we in the western world need to leave by
example
projects like this will make a
difference
if we do nothing not only do we
jeopardize the future of our own
children and black children
but he is the poorest in the world which
would be most affected
i therefore implore you to support this
application
thank you for your time and
consideration
thank you mr baranov
right well that that concludes the
contributions from the public
[Music]
of course
we actually
we did have a site visit
uh we went down independently this is
the
members of the public we went down
independently because we thought it went
in convoy in our cars you flock at the
lanes down there and i went down last
week i think other members had been down
and i got out when i walked around the
area and i thought what a lovely area
that is it's not an area that i knew
very well yeah i know holes weren't
enough i left over on the main roads
through northwest worthy
but this particular area around pie
world
so i was interested to look at it
so it's not just
the views from driving up on the narrow
lanes of the car
but once you're out and walking about
you get glimpses through hedges and
field gateways
and it is a lovely area um there's a lot
of woodlands
thick banks of trees in some areas and
i'm impressed with the whole area
so the issue of course as we all know
boils down to
what is an industrial
uh
imposition in the area and for solar
panels
and all that goes with it and the
construction of that especially the
agricultural use
the wildlife in the area and the
biodiversity
so i'm not i've got a few things that
i'm not saying anymore it's like
the members of the committee just let
so i was
very keen to have a look just to get a
little idea as to
you know what the land type was like
really now to be fair i didn't walk
fields
you know i don't look over the hedge but
you can get a fair idea
of what land is like just by looking at
it in vegetation so on
um and the conclusion is it's pretty
typical of
most of the land in the holes for the
area
um
i mean we're all used to farming we all
have fields some of which are wet some
which are dry
or drier
and
not being able to get onto lands um in
the late autumn or early spring is
nothing nothing unusual
um most feels
[Music]
it's pretty similar to most of the land
so it's no i wouldn't say it's no worse
or no better than any other land around
so
um with lots of agriculture around the
point of view i would sort of suggest
that it is
to do a lot of the thoughts
thank you council dalton
[Music]
um
i will just well the next member's thing
can just be
that forty percent as you've heard of
this land is grade 3a
which is best and most versatile
and the other 43 3b moderate quality
agricultural land i think probably as
councillor board was just
alluded to
and the land character type for this
area which is
main character type 5a
has medium to high sensitivity to
large-scale
pv development photovoltaic development
which this is definitely a large-scale
proposal
and anyone else like to make comments
yeah i'm very aware that we've got to
make a very balanced decision on this
application
um and i've read with great interest the
response from my worthy parish council
um and i particularly don't did uh what
the second supporter said who is the
farmer
and because i'm
married to a dairy farmer well we gave
up far dairy and some time ago and i
know the interest that they plan to give
up therein within two years anyway i
don't quite understand that because the
way that farming is going um no one
knows what's going to happen
um if you've read the nfu letter
um they completely support the
application the nfu
um and i won't go into the um
lan classifications because that's all
commented
um
but
with regard to the number objections we
all know that we must make a decision
not on the number of objections it
doesn't matter if you've got one
objection or a fail
you've got to make your decision on
planning policies and
ppf and other material considerations
i know there's been lots of objections
that are all on the planning portal
there are 667
people on the electoral roll for
pipeworthy and 395 properties so driving
around and i did spend two hours riding
around and i've got my map that i
highlighted and went all around so i do
know the area quite well
i mean
and a lot of the objections come from
the same household which i mean there's
11 under one name there's nine under
another name
and there's even one objection from the
sid found association which is a civic
society for cydna
so
i'll take that with a picture so um
i do agree with what they were that the
traffic survey wasn't done at the best
time
obviously because the code and the
schools weren't there
um
and they have got a number of soda red
in the area but at the moment the
landscape is dominated by the huge
electric pylons that are there already
um
[Music]
i will stop there for a minute other
members but i've got other points to
raise in a minute
okay thanks councilman christie yeah
thank you um well this is one of those
occasions where
the proof of being on the planning
committee is a poison chalice
we all know we're going to upset
somebody
whether the applicant or the objectives
we know that
um
i was intrigued by this because there
are various issues that left out of me
from this
when you look at the objections and
there's a lot of them a lot of them
because
we're not allowed to take into account
we all know this about the views
nobody owns a view
house values all that sort of thing
which always crops up
but we know we can't take those into
account but i did look back uh i was
interested in the cumulative impact of
this because
i look back at criminal cop farm which
has a solar farm of 17 hectares
interesting enough when that came up a
few years ago there was one objection
times change clearly and it's all about
the size i suspect
and
it's very difficult to get your head
around what 66 hectares is
to be honest
um i had a quick look at our local plan
uh winsford between abbeson road and
cleveland road just over the hill over
here which this committee passed it's in
our local plan 71 hectares
it's actually bigger and that's one
housing estate in biddeford it's
actually bigger than this which i found
interesting the other one was at the
back here cadstown ajavin
again very contentious
uh 60 hectares
so it gave it helped me enormously to
see what that meant actually and put
that into context
and there were a few other aspects that
caused me to look again the land quality
i have read the report carefully and i
heard the farmer just now
and
that was interesting but i i can't
really comment on that i'm not a farmer
like councilman but
i found it interesting
we do have better quality land we've got
worse quality land
it varies enormously over britain it's a
mosaic
um the views i've already mentioned
you don't know the view so talking about
you know views and we heard from the
officer who i have to say thank you for
all the viewpoints we saw what it would
look like
and we realized i think that
in terms of
impact on the landscape
it's not as huge as
possibly wind turbines turbulence
we know this but
i i have to pick up on something council
lockers just said pylons
about 20 years ago there was an
application for wind turbines down here
and i was invited down
i wasn't on planning committee i was
invited down as a councillor who had
chaired various local
meetings um i was invited down by the
local group to see these and they drove
me around in the land rover and we saw
where all things were
and i said to them at the end i said but
you know the thing that hits me is these
huge pylons
oh they've been here a long time and we
we're used to them
everyone gets used to things in the end
i know it's an initial problem anyway
another aspect that i was interested in
was tourism it's mentioned quite a lot
about the impacts on tourism in this
area
and yet north devon already has a lot of
solar farms is there any evidence that
having solar farms has actually hit
tourism because this year
we had a huge
boom of tourism i know it's because of
kobe you can't go abroad but is there
any evidence for
solar farms actually
impacting on tourism
can i ask
[Music]
i don't know of any evidence that's
christine i'm not sure
any evidence in the deliberation of the
application but not actually
right john thank you well i'll leave it
there
i i did as far as tourism but i did see
on
this application actually it made local
news
9 last night on bbc
and there was a chap on there who's
bought some
lazarus which will overlook this side
he's been there a few years developing
holiday bodies there he looked straight
into this
site so
i didn't imagine it's likely to affect
his holiday business there but
that was just on television last night
on the news
um
oh yes thank you chair
yeah uh
i really
understand where peach is coming from
actually
um as far as i know about tourism you
only have to look in cornwall
but the amount of solar farms the amount
of wind turbines
and what i know about cornwall because i
only live a mile away from it is it
already don't really really
care whether they're there or not
you know what to me i've known holiday
makers come down
to devon and stay at a place not not far
from us
who want to go out and look at the wind
turbines because they thought they were
great and fine they could be great
that's okay
uh and the land situation
like peter and and and
say
you know we have to look at it in the
sense that um
um do we really
think this is too big or
the farmer the farm the farmer over
there
he i thought he i thought what he said
was really good to be quite honest and
and i i appreciate him being honest
um but i'll just wait and see what
anybody else wants to say now i think
rhodes wants to come back in
okay did that counselor wise
[Music]
because we had one grade three field and
the rest of it was grade four and grade
five
and it was all productive and it was a
productive problem
so
i'm i'm struggling to to to see this
grade three a and b as being not very
productive land i was almost perfect
i'm now involved in a holiday park and
i've never known
the view of solar panels
to be an issue
with any of them with any of our
customers
from where we are we can see wind
turbines and that's never been raised
either strangely enough
um i can see there was a number of
concerns of being raised by statutory
commentary commenters and they've
basically all been answered in the
conditions
i am conflicted though because it is so
big
it is a big development
okay we've got bigger housing states and
if one were to look at the percentage of
land taken up
in the uh in a pine worthy parish it'd
be interesting to know what percentage
this represented
that was part of the whole
but we also have this responsibility
don't win
for
reducing carbon and that is becoming
more and more serious i see that at the
best at the best
rates
renewable energy produces no more than
20
of our electricity needs that was on the
very best day most days is a great deal
less
in the future we are going to need
something like three times the energy
electricity production we have now
so i think we can all see how this is
going to go
perhaps you know our local plan we're
working we need to have some reflection
on that and
answer that question
but at the moment
yeah i was rather surprised to see that
there was no response from ritual parish
council
so i actually went on bridgford parish
council website
and trawled through all their minutes
and found that on the minutes of the 20
uh march 21
their comments contained in the minutes
where the parish council have no
objections in principle but would ask
that consideration be given to him
on the impact of some residents so they
have no objection in principle
um going on to natural england um
i know their response
um
now i've got a farmer in my world who
had a soda farm albeit not so big as
this
but he has told me that he's seen such
an increase in wildlife especially um
nest inverse and the specifically
mentioned reigns
because they build their nests under the
panels and you see he's got a lot more
pheasants and partridges and he even
sees more hairs and hedgehogs
and he mows between the rides twice a
year
and that in itself creates and attracts
lots more ladybirds bees and other
insects so i don't think we will we will
be losing anybody biodiversity on that
one
um
[Music]
it was mentioned about the solar panels
being
um manufactured in china and slavery and
things like that well that is not a
material planning consideration where
the solar panels come from and that was
born out in a recent press um statement
from maria bailey of northern district
council that you cannot consider that
as i mentioned i'm very concerned about
making a balanced decision
um
and i don't know if you've all read
the latest objection from cpre and it
has been quoted again today
that mid devon planning committee turned
down an application for a farm at
langdon near clumpton
despite it being recommended by officers
however they fail to mention
that north devon district council plans
committee in may 21 you nanos voted to
approve 150 acres of
farm at newton tracy which above torres
district council's land so they have
approved one
um
and council they're not going to just
bring you back with respect
to this application and to the planning
policies that we have to consider this
on well i'm trying to point out that
we've got to make a bad decision
[Music]
but
i think and i've heard one or two other
members mentioning other things that
aren't really directly related to this
application i would rather members
discuss the actual thing how many does
my mobile doesn't respond
to what the public speakers said of what
we can consider what we
yeah there are many policies
that speak about land use in total in
north carolina
and i've made notes of some of them
and the mppf
as well now and national policy planning
policy guidance
speaks about renewable energy energy
proposals
and
there's lots of
what we've got to consider is the impact
of such a large development norm is
arguing against green
uh energy provision and renewable energy
information but in this specific
application we've got to look at its
impact
on that area of pipeline so close to the
w
that's really what we're going to look
at and that's why i've spent hours and
hours drawn with you only
and when you look at the
people we've written in the objections i
know
some of them you can't
take into account because they're not
material but there are some very good
planning policy reasons that people have
written in objecting and i think we're
not doing it justice unless we do
address those reasons
so
whilst whatever other councils may or
may not have done i'd rather just stick
to this one and the policies related to
this one
and i think that's what we should be
doing because it's so contentious
um but i'll bring in
i'm saying that just with respect i'd
just like to keep us focused on this
application and all the policies that we
need to
well i was just purely trying to put the
balanced argument into place and i too
was spent hours reaching it and then
started the mpps so i would stop there
and come back later i mean thank you
council i mean many of the objectives
have said they support green energy they
support
you know renewable energy i think
probably we always support we all
support but it's is it appropriate in
certain locations
a development of this size i'll bring in
councillor golf who stand their ways in
patients
thank you mr chairman yeah definitely
basically now just a couple quick
questions from me um i've
heard what landowner said about cop 26
and he alluded to the poorest being
affected in the world but that's true
and but
does the
installation of this solar panel farm
maybe potentially going through how does
that benefit the residents within the
village of pioneering
does it reduce our electricity bill
and this comes on to the social economic
gains
regardless of the
um renewable power etc
will the poorest of that village be able
to
actually gain some profit from this
nearby reduced electricity bills because
this is the main aim in my view of going
forward any solar power going through
does it go back to national good but
it's lost forever we don't actually the
villagers don't villagers don't actually
gain from this so that comes in a social
economic game you know it could be a
possibility to residents
and it's just the club's the close
proximity of it um to the village itself
and to me our class is is industrial
it's not one or two so fast it's a
large-scale industrial
solar farm
okay now i can see only one place can be
gaining from it wouldn't be the
villagers it'd be unfortunately the
landowner
so where it comes back through the
balanced effect to me
is
you've got to do it both ways the ladder
is keen he doesn't want to do any dairy
farming anymore
that's his view okay you've got other
businesses with any village which is
tourism based as well you could be
potentially harming the tourism of the
area
by
putting in a great big soda farm now
it's me
the water epson flows twice daily
atlantica right fantastic why hasn't
there ever ever been vote for him on a
large scale
why would we why are we building english
point
we're building hinckley point because
it's effective
effective
this to me only gains a small minority
of people and it's not the village
there's a part where we're going to get
into this whatsoever so
would it would it get cheap to achieve
electricity
it is a social impact
who's going to make offerings
thank you
councillor brown
and then councilman
i've listened with interest to what the
other members of friends of what they're
saying and it's uh
in the eye of the older isn't it really
but for me
75 000 panels
one mile
from end to end
lots of farmland
and the buildings associated with these
panels
looks to me very industrial
and not very nice for the tourism
with um tourism although they might have
some high hedges there if you're going
to visit a little place
most people will go online and see what
it has to offer and to me if they do
that and look at privately
it would look as if they've landed on
the moon
because it'd be nothing but a sea of
solar panels so for me i can't be voting
for this chairman that's my opinion
thank you councilman council christian
yeah i think i just want to follow up
with a couple of points that
councilman goffman because i think
they're important uh this idea of
benefit to locals i think it's something
we need to push in our local plan
because at the moment
we can't do that
if we could i'm sure a lot of our
communities would
actually run for these things because as
they do in denmark where the local
village actually builds them in order to
get the benefits uh our government won't
allow us to do it one of the points that
hasn't really been looked at and you
talk about the impact on this area is
there aren't that many sites that can be
used
because they have to be next to the
national grid
this is why at homesworthy or
agribusiness center or that huge expanse
of roof could not be used because
the cost of putting into the national
grid
is exorbitant and so the number of sites
it can be used it's actually
not that many and so this is perhaps why
this is being chosen we heard from the
applicant's agent this is one of the
reasons
um
as for alternatives well we know in our
local plan we're not allowed we can't
even look at wind turbines now
and the atlantic array that counts as a
government thing um i'm sorry but the
cpre speaker cpre opposed that um you
think do they actually support anything
you know we have to have some renewables
and they have to go somewhere and
unfortunately where they can go is
limited
thank you i would like to agree with
what council officially does then
but the areas that we can actually use
for solar panels are very limited by the
grid
i've been involved in trying to get
solar panels and one few days in
biddeford and the grid is not sufficient
to take
the energy that would be produced
i think it's entirely due to the fact
that we don't have a national plan
for energy production and that the
government prefers to leave it to
market solutions i mean we know that the
great
if
and there is
limited
um
land that can be used because of this
that it has to be near some station i
think we have to provide
um solar energy because we're not
allowed to provide more turbine
the government's not investing in
long-term solutions like weight
and
tidal energy than it should be and um
you know with it when it's a market
system
the only people who uh make any money
out of it is
the rich and the powerful
but there is there should have been
negotiations
[Music]
[Music]
and looking at the hedge rows
um we saw a five-year
montage of the hedgerows and i really
think it's it's not acceptable that we
should have wait five years
for the hedgerow to be there i think
i've been able to ask are they dead in
banks and will they be substantially
higher than fields and um
can there be more substantial planting
beyond the hedge
so we're gonna can we have some more
trees
because i i can't see very many trees in
the plan i'd like to ask
how many additional trees will we put in
i think i did read somewhere accounts of
gravy that they are to be kevin h
where the replays hedges that's correct
jeff yes we did clarify that one they
asked me on the devon
with the hedge fund on top
um
and in relation to the trees
unfortunately
the the plan that's there
does require a huge amount of
magnification there are trees that are
proposed
in two positions one of the eastern
banks of the northeastern part near
sub-station and parked in the
south western corner as well and they
are indicating this very small
circles which i make sure they're
struggling to find now i do have a
can you problem you tell us the
approximate number of new trees
can i bring the plan over to you it's
just that okay
is it i have a paper copy
laura you're not gonna figure for how
many new trees you could provide
30 40 50.
just where new trees have been planted
yeah
well i
[Music]
i mean they're already taking a
substantial amount of agricultural lands
being said for the solar panels i think
would not be
in the village
lake cottage
um and then there are some further ones
to the north eastern corner of the site
again
2013 circles are indicated on the planet
thank
[Music]
you think it was going to just be
totally really touched on the
accumulated cumulative effect of this
development i mean
with what's already in the area
renewable energy provision in the area i
should say that that area is taking its
fair share for torridge
of renewable energy production
and
national planning policy guidance does
say that cumulative impacts require
particular attention and i do think this
is critical they're very very close
together when i drove down there last
week and got a clinical on the road you
can see through the hedge and see
critical and then further on you go and
you come to the substation
and you can see when we have the earlier
map showing critical in relation to this
they're very close together and i think
human cumulative impact
needs consideration as well
but again
national planning policy guidance
does say and i'll
draw your attention to page 35 of the
report
and it's the third paragraph down
guidance in relation to assessing the
landscape impacts of the new renewable
energy
proposals is set out in the mbpg and not
so much
page 35
yeah which paragraph one two thirds
[Music]
and the nppg guidance does not say
these should consider both direct and
indirect effects of cumulative impacts
and temporary and permanent impacts
in order to assess the significance of
impacts a number of criteria should be
considered including the sensitivity of
the landscape and visual resource the
magnitude
or signs of the predicted change which
in this instance i don't think anyone
would deny its way
and noting that some landscape character
types may be more sensitive to certain
types of change than others which this
most certain is as i said at the start
lct 5a which is this
the landscape character here
has medium to high sensitivity to
large-scale pv development
so the arguments around
you know that we've got to produce
renewable energy it's not around that at
all it's around this for me this
particular application and this location
if this application came up
in a different location we might accept
that that in an island but when you look
at our policies
to do with the landscape particularly
and biodiversity
and the
biosphere in the area all those things
we've got a lot of policies in there
that this was
if they're not well contrary to in some
instances
so
this is what this is when i
and again some of the objectives and i
take what council lock said earlier one
objection carries as much rate in a way
there's two thousand or we don't make a
decision on the number of objections but
when you do read through those
objections
it may very good policy reasons
that they should be refusing this
application
and as i said some of them as
keen supporters of renewable energy and
i think we don't
you know we don't want to do a
disservice by not
addressing the policy issues
i'm very disappointed that there's no
environmental impact
assessment being conducted on this side
which would have been taken apart over
12 months period that's not happening
and it should have done with something
as large as this this environmental
impact assessment should have been done
but there's there was a war called in
october
and then most of its guest best
i asset assessment which for me isn't
good enough for something of this
magnitude
and
again we've said about the
the best and most versatile man
40 percent of it mean
all this is going against our own
policies that we use this we should and
we if we've not got the brownfield sites
as was mentioned in the church district
well i'm sorry i'm not what the very
clear site that doesn't mean we've got
to start with the industrial
developments on the greenfield sites
where there's good agricultural land
involved
and this is what the dilemma is it's
facing us we've got to weigh that
um the silver
i think sean's listening with intently i
thought he was going to say something
the solar
uh the energy
uh devolved from summer does fluctuate
well we all know
[Music]
and obviously in the summertime that's
the best time for solar panels to
generate on housing on large industrial
buildings
and we've got them on the riverbank
house of course and they do a job there
but when we when we're looking to put
them in in our lovely countryside we
really do have to be very very careful
um
what i said earlier when i said about
the agricultural side of stuff what i
would be getting it was i didn't think
it would be justified on the basis of
the agricultural land quality but i do
take on more of what cancer christie
said but obviously you know we lose land
all over the place into development and
a lot of cases good quality that so that
was my point there really but um you
know i do recognize there are positive
benefits as well and one of the things i
did notice council mock said is that um
richard parish council made no objection
at all and
i think my concern you know the mainstay
under visual is probably as
[Music]
opposed to it on the basis of losing
over 400 pounds i hate to see how it
goes
wherever it is but um you know i do
recognize there are benefits as well so
i am i'm still slightly taller
thank
you
counselor
um
right
it's a very very very balanced decision
and i've spent hours i'm sure all of us
and even days contemplating and
rewinding
devon county council flood risk
assessment have got no objections
natural england no objections subject to
mitigation conditions
the environment agency withdrew their
objections with their second response
the environmental protection officer has
got no objections with the appropriate
conditions
and the devon county historic
environment team of no objections and
condition number six covers that and our
own tdc conservation officer
uh considers the heritage impact
assessment is fair so on balance i'm
going to recommend approval of this
application subject to the additional
conditions or amendments that the
planning officer made
thank you councillor
and
do i have a second one yes
right on page 37.
draw your attention to the fifth
paragraph down or the third paragraph
from the bottom of the page
in terms of landscape effects
the review the review we had them
concludes that on-site
and within the immediate surrounding
area to the application site up to
approximately a kilometer
the development would appear out of
place and bring about a noticeable
change in landscape character
in the wider area the development is
considered to result in a noticeable
change in landscape character when
considered cumulatively with other
developments and we've all seen them
back with the other
renewable schemes in the area
so
i'll revert back to the and i'll go back
to policy issues
before we go to any role
the policy uh the pyro this spatial
strategy
speaks at d of retaining the character
of the village and protection of the
local and natural environment
and that's a special strategy for
bioware
also our policy sdo7
special development strategies for
london and denmark's rural areas
um
and pinewood is classed as a
schedule b village
up for the countryside beyond local
centers villages and rural settlements
development will be limited to that
which is enabled to meet local economic
and social needs rural building reuse
and development which is necessarily
restricted to a countryside location
all that speaks to obviously found time
diversification
schemes which which this isn't
and policy sd14 enhancing environmental
assets
at sea
conserving european protected species
and habitats
on which they depend this seriously
affects that
then d conserving northern demons geo
diversity at its best and most versatile
agriculture
it doesn't do that it's
it's against that
protecting and enhancing local landscape
and seascape character taking into
account the key characteristics
the historical dimension of that
landscape and their sensitivity to
change and i'll go back again to this
landline
character type friday there is medium to
high sensitivity to large scale pv
development
so
we've got the policies here
and
that little conservative enhancing the
robustness of northern devon's
ecosystems and the range of ecosystem
services they provide
[Music]
i think
one of the other councillors one of the
other committee members
who mentioned the renewable er the
policy st-16 delivering new renewable
energy and heat
at a
three a landscape sensitivity that's
able to accommodate them if you're going
down
but this is it certainly goes against
that
renewable and at four renewable low
carbon energy development other than
wind management will be supported but it
can demonstrate that the cumulative
impact of operation of consented and
proposed development on landscape
character does not become a significant
or defining characteristic of the wider
fabric
character and positive landscape
that counselor would go
that famous show that wasn't to get you
to shut up at all basically what i'd
like to do vote for nature is to
propose we refuse this application on
st07
it has been proposing secondly to grant
this so graffiti was the vote on that
first unless you want to make an
amendment okay
i would like obviously i would like to
continue talking if i can't obviously
oppose refuse that's what i'd like to do
on it on st 07 st
st16 can't
not in my backyard unfortunately you
know someone at some don't want it okay
some people getting money from it other
people won't make money from it i'm not
interested in the financials of it
as a council we have to really get
together with north devon we have to
challenge the government we have to
change our local plan
for wind energy
atlantic array out the way of everything
change some of the shipping lanes out
there is to me the only solution i can
see going forward to actually future
proof in this area and future
generations again wind energy to me is
the way we need to go north we sold the
panels if we're going to do that we
should have stipulated solar panels to
be put on every new
side of bui just constantly inside you
know that's the only efficient way of
getting this electricity back into these
landscapes where they can actually gain
what should be gained unfortunately this
is industrial use only the installers of
this industrial site are going to make
money from them residents will not make
money from this one it's going to go
back to the national grid the national
grid will not reduce the cost to the
householders
to me that social economic is no benefit
to whatsoever so i'm not in favor
whatsoever on those facts i just want to
make it clear mr chairman i have no
background indeed what's going on
wind parrot is the only way to go yeah
and cancer chris has done it for years
you know waiting for his counsellor
i've always been interested for his
cancer he's always harped on it it needs
to you know we got to be proactive and
actually stand up
and challenge us you know to me atlanta
great to meet the only way i can see it
going through
and you can slip and cop i'll just bring
in sean our planning manager
yes thank you a very good discussion um
just highlighting again reminding
members that we do have our experts on
landscape and ecology as a cumulative
impact has been discussed at length and
it may be worth members asking
particular questions on that element and
also with the chair to mention about the
ecology assessment and as we have the
approaches here in the colleges again if
there's any direct questions maybe
useful for members
council christian well yeah well i was
actually going to mention that um and i
welcome councilman goff i'm sure he'll
get in touch with jeffrey and ask him to
change the law
that's what that's what it means
if you look at page 40.
page 40 the second paragraph now
um
storage did actually commission an
independent review of the landscape
study and it says the independent review
of the landscape study the lbia
considers that cumulatively the proposed
development will result in a moderate
adverse cumulative effect now we've got
devon county rhodes office here i'm sure
can explain what moderate means
because we keep having it don't we a
weasel what does it mean but it does go
on to say that um a moderate adverse
cumulative effect in terms of impact on
landscape character however the effects
of the development would not be
noticeable outside of the study area of
two kilometers which
you know i presume that's where it's
come from but the question i wanted to
ask was something raised actually i
thought was a really interesting point
one of the objectives
um
at the end of this life and everyone
talks about the land being lost
no it's the land in biddeford that's
being built i have houses on that's
being lost
this one is going to revert
to agricultural use i see
but somebody raised the issue could it
be a brownfield site because if it is
that needs to be written into our thing
that it cannot be
classed as a brownfield site after being
used
of course
i think probably you remember cancer
christians the definition
of a ground field selective and
unless sean corrects me his previously
developed land which this would be
remember
well
sure
yeah
thank you chair thank you christine um
the mbpg actually touches on this and it
says that it returns to its previous use
previously
so it cannot become a brownfield side
not every previous us
that's cool
country christian did you want to ask a
specific question no no that was the
point
[Music]
but you said what does moderate mean
only because we've had this time and
time again having what was moderate
moderate to something is something else
for somebody else
[Music]
yeah
i prepared the independent review
um and the first thing that i did was to
come up to the microphone yeah and then
everybody can need it
thank you thank you the first thing i
did was look at the methodology that the
landscape architects who produced the
landscape visual impact assessment can
use and i found that that was fit for
purpose
and so my review was based on that
methodology
and um in
appendix um
uh appendix one page thirteen
of the lvia it it describes a range of
um
of effects criteria
a moderate adverse is described in there
as um
in terms of landscape character the
development would have a noticeable
change to the landscape where it would
appear to be out of place and and that's
what i found
certainly within that sort of one
kilometer at the site and um
but by the time you get around about two
kilometers from from the site that
effect dissipates
so that that's that's what modern means
and it's on a
is on a scale that
runs from
major beneficial effects through to
major adverse and moderates as it says
sort of sort of in the middle between no
change you know and a major effect
and while you're there i'd like to ask a
question because i made a note here that
the landscape visual impact assessment
the lva ia
recommends best practice assessment
should be set from five kilometers from
the site this one was only separate two
kilometers
and i think if best practice is what is
recommended that's what should have
happened in this case
the um the the the landscape visual
impact assessment and started off with a
five kilometer study area
um and then um in the same way that i
did they found that beyond about two
kilometers the effects were negligible
or no change which is i'm imagining why
they've honed in on that that two
kilometers but it is best practice to to
start with a larger area and then if you
discover effects in those larger those
larger that larger area to take those
into account
um but um it's not unusual for for those
for the study area to be honed in
into the area where where there are
going to be effects and those are things
obviously that you need to take into
account
thank you
would you recommend any
specific areas where extra treats would
be added because i'm mindful to um
move to accept this with another
condition
that there should be more um screening
with woodlands
planting hedgerows expressions
[Music]
where where the site is
is is most
visible and where those visual effects
are greatest
they they tend to be
from places where there are long views
towards the summit
um and the the viewpoints that were
taken were representative viewpoints
and and the best way of screening it
would be
you know where those viewpoints are
rather than at the site because
um
the the
tree planting of hedge planting has the
most effect when it's closest to the
viewer rather than
closest to the thing you're trying to
scream because
you know that the land the land dips
somewhat so
um a bit of tree planting actually on
the site um
would
would apart from any one of two
locations
which have been picked up it wouldn't
really have a
huge effect on the um
on the visibility of the
of the proposal
and
um and i think there is there is hedge
planting proposed in in in a few places
i think people
uh viewpoint three is one of them where
the viewer is quite close to the site
and hedge funding is proposed to to
mitigate that that change
um
from a landscape point of
view
it would be great if that hedge had some
trees in it
um but i
i can't really answer as to how that
would affect the operation of the solar
farm
thank you any more questions
for no
thank you very much for your comments
mentioning uh viewpoint three which you
did it's proposed to close that up
that's currently a farm gateway that
will be closed up with a new bit of
hedging
so that's one view that will be lost
because it's going to be
it's going to be blocked with hedging
and
i don't think i have anything else down
apart from the fact that
the screening that's proposed in the
agricultural assessment
of course is more effective in the
summer months when there's lots of
leaves in the trees in full
leaf
and the hedges as well so
i think if we had this
landscape visual impact assessment
sorry the environmental impact
assessment which i mentioned
over 12 month period we'd have got a lot
better view of
the wild life the floor and form and how
it would affect it i think it's a shame
that wasn't done and insisted upon but
it's not been done
right well we'll go to the vote to start
with it if that law is lost we'll go to
an alternative one but they vote
back outside secondly by councillor
watson
to approve the application
so will you take the
[Music]
[Music]
councilman golf against councillor
watson four
councillor wiseman
that's five four chair and four against
thank you chandra
that application
me
our next application
application
0983 2021
full application on page 16 of your
agenda and again it talks to laura to
present this that's
[Music]
to create eight one-bedroom supported
living units together with ancillary
staff accommodation and various
facilities
and just by the way an update to the
office report we've received one further
letter of support
from the agent for the applicants of the
publication of the officers report
and this reiterates the original
proposal for the development which is to
be used as specialist housing
accommodation
rather than as an hmo as a multiple
occupation
and it's intended to be occupied by
those requiring an element of care due
to learning difficulties and or autism
um i believe this let's also be
certified to the members of
so here you guess presentation
and the applications are identified in
red see the root on the right hand side
new roads which runs
the right hand side of the site north
south and torridge hill which runs down
on the opposite side
with the
applications like the brunswick house
itself and annex and then part of the
warehouse
excuse me what's the blue bit then it's
in the athlete's ownership
it's the remainder of the warehouse
thank you
so much about showing much the same and
just to make numbers aware the fact that
the
site behind the actual search of the
north of it
is in commercial use
and nearest residential property is
called the folly which is
set just to the south west of the site
but as members you know the area will
know that that's at quite the height and
changing levels above the level of the
highway and the application site at that
point so you don't see the two
necessarily in the same context
and so these taken along the road
towards the rear of the site it's like
the thing with the scaffolding on it
and then view from the corner
conjunction
of the application site
and then a view of the parking area and
which
buildings vehicles at the moment the
part of the warehouse to the left-hand
side is sought to be demolished to a
large parking area
different parking spaces and you can see
signals
you can see the single story element
behind the buildings around there but
that's the annex known as the pigeon
house
[Music]
this is inside the property there's an
existing kitchen which will be used as
the proposed communal kitchen for
residents
i believe so
this is the proposed ground floor can
you live in space
and then there's a first floor living
space as well
so
laura
they've already started it now
they're doing some internal alterations
yes
so this is the existing block plan so
you can see the main two-story dwelling
with brunswick house
the pigeon house and the annex to them
to the rear
and then you can see the other grey blob
within the red line is the
existing warehouse which is thought to
be demolished
and then the proposed site plan then
shows in place of that warehouse we
would have additional parking spaces and
an increased visibility
[Music]
apologies for the poor crossing plans
they don't come up very well on a
powerpoint slide uh this is the existing
ground floor plan
the proposed graphical plans which shows
how the existing accommodation will be
used so you've got four one bed units
on the ground floor and your you've got
a communal living space community
kitchen and an office
to be used by staff
and then
again the first floor plan
is internal operations that are proposed
so you can see the large communal living
space the right hand side there and then
we've got four further units on the
first floor and then there's a small
staff bedroom accommodation also
[Music]
proposed elevations and existing
elevations no alterations are proposed
so guarantee the main kind of
considerations and the applications that
is within
the settlement boundary of biddeford so
in terms of its principle
it's an existing dwelling house um
obviously st 17 seeks to provide
specialist housing within such locations
to meet an identified need as members
will have seen we've got a sporting
letter from the applicant there's one
studies from dublin county council
confirming that they're working with the
applicant to provide a specialist form
of
supported accommodation and also from
northern care trust and which that
better relates specifically to the
application site and development and say
that they're in partnership with the
applicant
and the proposed accommodation
and its need is highlighted in both
letters so this the development is
considered to be keeping the policy
st-17
in terms of the partial demolition of
the warehouse and
this is considered to be keeping the
policy dm-13 in relation to employment
use
the existing commercial use will be
retained within the remaining portion of
the warehouse building
which is more than sufficient to meet
the current occupants it needs
um
but also to mention about an element of
employment generation of the nature of
the use of staff provision on
site and the impact on character and
appearance and the existing external
appearance would remain unaltered and
the nature of the use would be is
considerably keeping the character the
surrounding area
and
whilst the application site is within
the conservation area it's not a result
this development has a harmful impact on
the conservation area or the setting of
nearby listed buildings
in terms of residential amenities uh the
produce is not considered to result in
half an impact on the amenities of
neighboring occupiers taking account of
where they are in relation to
development and it's considered a
suitable standard of amenity will be
provided for future occupants
in terms of access and parking
as the plan show would result in a
provision of six off-street parking
spaces
due to the nature of the proposed using
the proximity to public transport
services and services that are available
within the middle walking distance
it's considered an appropriate level of
parking provision will be made
in terms of drainage there'll be no
alterations to the existing surface or
barrel drainage arrangements and
there's no extensions or
additional hard surface areas to
increase well
[Music]
for ecology
we received a preliminary
rooster nest assessment as part of the
application
that doesn't identify any potential
for or any evidence of the use of the
building by bats
there is a potential domestic birds but
obviously this wouldn't be lost as part
of the development
and the assessment does propose
enhancements in terms of adding bird
boxes and this has been included
position three
of the recommendations
so the application seeks changing needs
to provide eight sports
uh living units together with your
answer and staff accommodation it's
considered to be people with national
and local policy and the recommendations
for agreement
thank
you we've got one speaker listed for
this one uh who's
speaking in support of it then it's the
agent laura lyon davis thank you
any second we've got three minutes to
present your case security
thank you chair and good morning members
firstly i trust that members have had
the opportunity to read my letter which
is included on the additional papers
this clearly sets out and addresses the
concerns raised by council of victory
who called the application to committee
on grounds that the units will be
classed as hmos and that there is
already a high concentration of these in
the area which can have an effect on
presidential immunity
in short the proposal seeks supported
living units which are considered to be
specialist housing probation rather than
unrestricted hmos
accordingly the development will
accommodate local people who require an
element of specialist care due to
learning difficulties or due to abortion
the applicant a registered social
housing provider will be delivering
these units in collaboration with devon
adult social care and the northern care
trust
this is evidenced by their supporting
letters which are also included within
your papers
as such there is clearly a requirement
for this type of specialist
accommodation within the area
furthermore prospective presidents will
be through referrals such as by the
local authority or social care and will
be delivering their long term under
homes for life tenancy which will be
made by the applicant
therefore none of the units will be left
to individuals who do not require
support
overall the principal development is
wholly in accordance with the policy st
107 of delay plan which supports
specialist housing accommodation where
they meet an identified likely need a
proportion to the other capacity on our
location at sustainable locations
in essence this is exactly the type of
development that planning policy
supports and in turn as elected members
we should support accounting committee
today
turning to neighboring immunity impacts
the proposed use would be entirely
compatible with neighboring occupiers
due to substantial separation distances
between properties and the science
location of the town center context
to add clarity it is worth noting that
16 neighbours formerly consulted about
this application process and not a
single objection letter has been
received
lastly your professional officer
confirms that the phrase development is
also acceptable in terms of impact or
character creates the area from access
and parking for drainage and ecology
consequently development is considered
to be in accordance with an upstate
development plan and there are no
adverse impacts that will significantly
and demonstrate outweigh the benefits
given a number of tendencies and
financial grants have already been
secured in principle it is vital that
its application is progressed positively
without any firm delays
members are therefore respectfully
requested to uphold the sponsor's
recommendation for approval thank you
thank you
councillor you'll see that bitcointown
council
well i was going to point that out thank
you yes um town council approved that um
it's a beautiful building uh if you get
a chance to go inside it's got lots of
absolutely fascinating features but if
you look if you all know where it is
it's an unfortunate site today
it's got no garden it's you know it's
it's a problem it's got industrial
estates around it's got roads next to it
and it's so good to see this building
being used for a social purpose so i'll
propose that we accept this and i'll
second that cheers for watson yeah
anybody else like nick
got some fantastic views from that house
though there is some a bit about your
space at the front but it's not there's
some nice plants in that garden i've
seen flowering this year and i'll be
glad to see some of that derelict
warehouse coming down as well that would
be an improvement cancer a lot yeah
that's the first time i've seen
photographs of inside the house and i
picked up that it was an old building so
i was rather surprised there was no
response to my conservation officer
yeah in the conservation area i was
surprised
you can see it from the road have a look
at the garage
on the road in the ceiling there's
girders they're the last remaining rails
from the biddeford
over there with the mic so we can
[Music]
it's um moved to approved by councillor
christian certainly by councillor watson
sandra we take the vote
yesterday councillor banter
councillor brown
councillor christie or cancer craigie
[Music]
12 but we've got to now adjourn this
meeting
until one o'clock
would like to meet with me for the rest
of the agenda
i think the angelo's like yeah we could
have done the last one come on
hey
presume many
you